Whether they cut their teeth on the franchise
or added it to an already impressive resume,
what does the cast of Star Wars do after The
Rise of Skywalker?
We're here to find out.
Here's where you'll be able to find the stars
of the sequel trilogy after they leave that
galaxy far, far away.
Daisy Ridley was virtually unknown, with only
a handful of short film and TV credits to
her name, when she was cast as Rey in Star
Wars: The Force Awakens.
When the film was released in 2015, she became
an international star, opening a world of
new acting opportunities overnight.
With Episode IX completing Rey's on-screen
arc, Ridley will be free of certain film franchise
constraints, but she hasn't lined up a huge
number of projects just yet.
Even before she jumped into finishing Rise
of Skywalker she worked alongside Tom Holland
on Chaos Walking, a film that's been subjected
to repeated reshoots and, at the moment, does
not have a release date.
"Hey Daisy!
Does Rey go to the Dark Side?”
"Tom!
Come on!"
Still, that hasn't slowed Ridley down.
Among her announced post-Skywalker plans are
the World War II drama A Woman of No Importance,
in which she'll play spy Virginia Hall, and
the supernatural film Kolma, which has been
in the works for several years and is rumored
to be part of the Cloverfield universe.
John Boyega was a bit better known than Daisy
Ridley when he signed on to play Finn in Star
Wars: The Force Awakens, because he'd already
been a part of one of the great cult films
of the 2010s: Attack the Block.
Since Star Wars entered his life, though,
Boyega's star has continued to rise.
Like Ridley, Boyega hasn't lined up a great
many projects following the conclusion of
his Star Wars trilogy, but what he does have
coming up sounds compelling.
His next film will be Naked Singularity, in
which he plays a public defender whose life
begins to unravel and who, at his wit's end,
decides to carry out a heist.
He's also set to appear in the upcoming British
miniseries Small Axe.
Oscar Isaac's career had already spanned more
than a decade and included an impressive series
of diverse and compelling roles by the time
Star Wars entered his life.
His accomplishments before a galaxy far, far
away included the likes of A Most Violent
Year, Sucker Punch, and Inside Llewyn Davis,
for which he was nominated for a Golden Globe.
After The Rise of Skywalker, Isaac will continue
to build on his already-impressive resume
with several projects, including another legendary
sci-fi story.
In 2020, Isaac will appear in director Denis
Villenueve's upcoming big-screen adaptation
of Dune, adding another major franchise to
his filmography.
His other upcoming films including the drama
Big Gold Brick and the thriller The Card Counter.
Prior to Star Wars, Adam Driver was best known
for his role as Adam on Lena Dunham's HBO
series Girls.
Somehow, that and his rising reputation as
a dramatic actor on the indie scene were enough
to secure him the role of the franchise's
new primary villain, Kylo Ren.
"I feel like he feels like he's in the right,
so what is there to be redeemed from?'
The role brought Driver international superstardom,
but he has continued to interweave small dramatic
roles with his franchise blockbusters, establishing
himself as one of his generation's boldest
actors.
Driver's career since his Star Wars role began
has already been quite exciting, and he's
not slowing down anytime soon.
His new Netflix drama Marriage Story was released
shortly before The Rise of Skywalker, and
his upcoming projects include the musical
drama Annette and Ridley Scott's next historical
epic, The Last Duel.
Domhnall Gleeson's career included a major
franchise well before Star Wars came along.
As his reputation grew in the early 2010s
he earned a role in the Harry Potter film
series as Bill Weasley.
When Star Wars: The Force Awakens needed a
secondary villain in the form of First Order
General Hux, director J.J. Abrams went with
Gleeson, cementing his place in another iconic
franchise.
After Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker, he'll
next be seen in Peter Rabbit 2: The Runaway,
in which he reprises his dual roles as Jeremy
Fisher and Thomas McGregor.
He's also set to make a major play for the
small screen with a new comedic thriller on
HBO called Run.
Star Wars: The Force Awakens had to introduce
a number of new characters to the world of
a galaxy far, far away, and make a worldwide
audience fall in love with them.
Star Wars: The Last Jedi had to build on that
new foundation, and to do that writer/director
Rian Johnson turned to Kelly Marie Tran.
At the time, Tran was relatively unknown,
with a resume consisting largely of small
TV roles.
As Resistance mechanic Rose Tico in The Last
Jedi, she reached an international level of
fame.
So far, Tran's kept a relatively low profile
outside of Star Wars, with her only other
major work coming in the form of the Facebook
Watch series Sorry for Your Loss with Elizabeth
Olsen, but that's set to change soon with
a pair of high-profile voiceover roles.
"Because it feels like it was a big franchise,
now I just want to do something totally different
and weird."
In the wake of The Rise of Skywalker, she's
set to co-star in The Croods 2 as Dawn, and
she'll also be joining Pixar's Monsters Inc.
franchise with a role in the upcoming Disney+
series Monsters At Work.
Mark Hamill could have stopped acting after
Return of the Jedi and he would have remained
a legendary pop culture figure forever thanks
to his portrayal of Luke Skywalker.
Thankfully, he did not stop, and the result
is a diverse career that's included many screen
acting roles and perhaps even more voiceover
roles.
In 2015, Hamill was drafted to return to the
Star Wars saga as Luke Skywalker, ushering
in a new phase of his career that has only
gained steam since.
So, what's next for Hamill?
Well, he could conceivably never stop playing
Luke Skywalker in various forms, but for the
moment he's turning to a new animation project.
Hamill has been cast as one of the voice actors
in the upcoming series Invincible, an adult-oriented
superhero series based on the Skybound Entertainment
comic of the same name, written by Walking
Dead co-creator Robert Kirkman.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.